[Music]
so we have a visitor over at the house
talking about the elliptic integrals and
periodic functions and things like this
and it's all derived from conic sections
and my wife Pat and I are listening we
could make some conic sections we could
not only make some comic sections we
could bake some we could make a cone and
slice it let's make iconic loaf of bread
or let's bring it in the kitchen kitchen
all right the timing on this is a little
delicate so I got up at six in the
morning to make the dough but then we
had to keep it from rising too much
until you got here Brady so so now I'm
hoping that it's going to be okay this
is what it looks like right now before
it's baked this is a funnel with the
bottom chopped off made of borosilicate
glass because it won't balance on one
end
Pat had the idea we'll put it in it's a
stock
a stockpot and we're going to grab that
end I'm going to go ahead and put it in
there
in the oven risen enough
curiously her first idea was to make
scones in a cone to have
conic sconic sections we'll see about
this in an hour okay how's it going Pat
I think it's alive I think it's growing
I'm afraid it'll go all the way up and
stick to the roof of the oven and then
we'll have a problem
[Music]
yeah that's pretty good sorry I almost
stabbed you
all right we now have
a conical loaf of bread
perfect time to do Connex right here's a
first thing let's draw an axes
here's the axis of the cone
if I cut perpendicular to this
I should get a circle
[Music]
hot damn
basic conic
a circle or really in this case a disc
because it's a filled in circle so if I
want a sandwich a circular sandwich
I could start here and make another one
[Music]
another disc now if memory serves me
right
I ought to be able to make an ellipse by
slicing
the bread at an angle
so let's try and lips
[Music]
oh yeah I've got an ellipse right here
I can make a steeper ellipse
a more elliptical ellipse by cutting
this way yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes
I don't have an ellipse I have an
elliptical slice of bread it looks a
little circular but if you look here
it's elliptical
so now
let's start pushing things now a
parabola is a conic section where it's
cut parallel to one of the sides
here
[Music]
here is a section of a parabola with a
bite taken out
if I rebuild this and I'd cut along here
this would have been a parabola
[Music]
a slice that's parallel to this axis is
a hyperbola
to get a hyperbola let's slice right
along here
[Music]
and there along here
is hyperbola
[Music]
cut here
without slicing my hand
a hyperbola along here pretty poor
hyperbola
with a little bit of
homemade plum jam
a hyperbolic Jam sandwich can't ask for
more
difficult
it's the unparabolic it tastes
hyperbolic it tastes like the orbit of a
comet that's coming in from an infinite
distance this is a sandwich
that's made in conic sections
[Music]
oh is that a circle
yeah sort of this is a homemade plum jam
oh that tree Brady is right now having a
circular disc plum jam sandwich
very good
come on does it taste conical
[Music]
does it taste extra good because it's a
homemade conic section I think can you
taste is it possible for you to
determine that every little yeast body
and every little grain of of organic
flour that's used in that
has
you know this iconic section
yeah I think I think I think I could
taste that
means you're going to figure this out
and do the experiment you're going to
find your own equipment if you don't
have a turkey around measure the
temperature of lasagna or measure the
temperature of chow mein